so we got a cheating gal here
let's give the cheating gal caller a
shot
hello
yo what's up Mr Richard Cooper yo
keep it keep it keep it as clean as you
can for YouTube but so what's the story
so what's going on here so why are you
here right now so basically I need this
girl from three years ago um she had a
bad pass I didn't read the book as yet
um she had a bad pass and a bad pass
like what do you mean like she had a
whole bunch of red flags yeah yeah she
had a whole bunch of red flags so she
she basically had sex with two guys
multiple times and then we did a
threesome on her and um whenever they
booked about a couple months ago
um I saw that she had these red flags
but I wasn't red pill at the moment so
now um
I've been away for about a year and I
came back to the country and then came
to find out hey she's been messing
around and um now she's asking for
forgiveness she's saying she's sorry I
could see that she generally genuinely
sorry and um when she went back the
first time to this guy she told him that
it was over she doesn't like it and then
when I came back in um March
um I knew something was wrong you know I
could have her Vibes wasn't with me
anymore you know let me let me guess
you're from the Caribbean sounds like
Jamaica maybe you left you went to
improve yourself make some more money
get a new degree something you came back
your situation improved am I close to
the truth here somewhere yeah yeah yeah
you're basically close not not Jamaica
but I'm in the Caribbean yeah so so you
came back with a new skill new new money
new uh Visa new passport maybe and she's
you know begging for forgiveness you
know what she did was was wrong and she
wants you to take her back
yeah basically so um she been she's been
giving me hints before she um actually
told me what happened like she told me
she she deleted Instagram but I never
really asked her why she told me that
you know and that was months before I
even found out so she's been giving me
and she said she didn't know how to tell
it to me what are the red flags that
this gal has
um first of all
um piercing she had one piercing on her
nose
um a pass was really bad you know she
was very young when she messed up and
she doesn't have a good communication
with her dad you know although she was
very young when she messed up you mean
she was very young when she lost her
virginity yeah very young yeah and
I'm assuming she's got a large Notch
count as a result of that too right no
right now not to come to that five I was
the fourth
how old was she when she lost her
virginity
um I believe at 14 14 19.
um and
what's so special about her like why
would you take her back
well basically the bond that we that we
have that we share you know she
basically helped me throughout my
struggles you know um when I needed a
little bit of cash you know she she
would give me some and um she never acts
back for it you know I told her in the
future I'm into cryptocurrency
um and I told her in the future you know
when I make it
um I'll help her and her family so she
doesn't have to work and she she stood
by my side throughout my struggles and
everything and she's really a
down-to-earth girl
um she's struggling she has it worse
than me and um yeah she you know and
French has a has a part to play in it as
well you know foreign
no
well my friend you know you left to go
do something and I'm assuming you left
her as a girlfriend a committed woman to
you like she'd claimed you you know at
that point
and you came back and you found out that
three guys ran a train on her
no no no that was before I met her
before you met her she had a threesome
yeah okay but so when you're away she
cheated on you with how many guys was it
one guy was it one day and she thought
that one guy four times sorry she had
back together four times yeah I I don't
I don't make any exceptions for this
it's like if a chick steps out on me in
the relationship after she's committed
to me especially if she's asked you know
for monogamy like she wants to claim me
and she steps out
it's goodbye I can't trust you you're a
hoe bye-bye that's it done there's
there's eight billion people on the
planet and you're telling me that you
can't replace this hoe with a woman that
can be loyal to you it doesn't matter if
she's bailed you out giving you money
took care of you when you had a cold or
a cough or whatever none of that stuff
matters because
men and women are different men men view
women differently than women view men
and you've come back as a better man
and you've come back to a chick that let
you down
I don't know why any guy would take that
back and I think that you know that
inherently like I think deep within your
core within your beliefs you're
disgusted by her I would be anyway so
why would you even contemplate taking
this woman back that you know ran around
behind your back and that's only the one
that you know about
yeah facts that's right you know um
well to be honest this was my first
heartbreak you know so it's like
congratulations my friend yeah you've
you've you've now you know begun Life as
a man yeah and this will let you down
they will break your heart they will lie
to you
women will cheat on you it's it's it's
it's in our nature right but women can
also be very kind and loving and uh
actually be faithful to you you know
some some women have that capacity but
as soon as somebody shows you who they
are believe them
they don't need second and third chances
because she'll do it again I guarantee
you
yeah I told her the same thing you know
because um
I wish I read your book much earlier you
know and but I mean it's life you know
I'm 20.
and I said to myself I pledge this to
myself when I was 18. I said I'm Gonna
Be A Millionaire by 25. and all these
girls that ditched me out in school you
know I'm gonna have them on my yacht you
know and you know what I'm gonna do to
them you know so you you go and Chase
that excellence and you go and you know
achieve that dream of yours because
this chick is not going to help you
achieve that she'll be an anchor
and you know it yeah yeah that's right
but um one thing right
um I was contemplating whether I should
you know still have a day on the side
whenever you know I I need her you know
um look man if you just want to use her
for recreational purposes and have a
Friends with Benefits type of
relationship do that do not marry this
chick do not invite her into your life
as a girlfriend do not take her on
vacations do not bring her over for
family events she's shown you who she is
believe her now
it it it never lasts though oh we lost
him uh you know situations like that you
know where you're like I just want to
sort of keep her around as an FWB sort
of thing it never lasts because at some
point
what she starts to do is she'll be like
well I I don't want to feel like I'm
being used and I have and I have um I'm
starting to have feelings for you right
um
and then they start to use that as a
bargaining tool right and you're like
well okay fine
sort of thing so personally
my advice is just cut her loose and go
chase Excellence you'll find something
better trust me I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out